hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to well
the big summer blockbusters are coming
up and guess which ones have the most
hype aside from that that's like from
that one to for the sake of this joke
I'm gonna say the Avengers and
Prometheus yes people are excited to see
these two big films premiere and why
shouldn't they be it got one film
directed by Joss Whedon and another film
about the Alien franchise quit so much
build-up between these two movies you
gotta wonder why nobody thought to put
Joss Whedon and the Alien franchise
together at some point oh my god Alien
Resurrection my god yeah how many of you
knew that the geek got a sci-fi actually
started off writing one of the dumbest
sci-fi flicks ever to hit the screen the
sequel was made in fam response to the
fact that nobody was satisfied with the
last and supposed final alien so they
made this flake to try and end it on a
stronger when really it was Hollywood's
Way of saying hey you think that's a bad
way than to franchise take a look at how
else we can fuck up this turkey throw in
the very natural selection of the
director from Amelie and you get a film
that surprisingly sluts out the dignity
of alien creatures who are more phallic
shape than out so let's see why in space
nobody can hear you sock this is alien
resurrection so they waste no time on
the resurrection part we see Ripley
played again by Sigourney Weaver brought
back to life through cloning 200 years
later after her death Jesus bringing
people back from 200 years ago there are
so many rap battles that can evolve from
this she's brought back so that
scientists can reproduce the alien
creature that was implanted inside of
her and seeing how this is a Joss Whedon
script I expect at least one of those
mad scientist's dancing along I'm
looking at you warm tongue blood and
guts slimy - shoulda stopped at movie -
Ripley is kept alive and flown in a Cell
until she regains consciousness
now from a symbolic standpoint the bank
represents rebirth and entering a new
world of life but from a reality
standpoint they're just dicks fuckin
around with her hey Harry you got the
giant novelty condom from Spencer's yeah
why don't we go ahead and put her inside
it you've been dreaming about this for a
while haven't so what if I have but we
quickly see that this Ripley is
different from the one before as some of
her DNA has mixed in with the alien and
made her a different kind of creature
for example she thinks the word fork his
fuck fork fuck she said fuck it's funny
it's a queen how did you know that
she'll breed you'll die
I think you will find that things have
changed a great deal since your time yes
like they have answered proof cells to
keep the aliens in a way they don't
well at least they have a general who
understands the scientific risks at
stake oh wait they don't well at least
they're not just relying on a bunch of
space pirates to bring up their
incredibly important card - oh for God's
sakes this operations as airtight as a
strain door yeah things have come a long
way since before but dumb is still dumb
don't cut the Russel about 600 meters
and give a little scare so like I said
before a bunch of renegade space pirates
bring prisoners for the scientists to
use as breeding grounds for the aliens
could you have a please sir
what could you answer please by the way
that's Ron Perlman that's one of the
pilots there no weapons allowed on board
sir
my own recipe way more dangerous could I
say my line any closer to the camera oh
when I kick the chair why yes that would
make a lot of sense when own a writer
playing the part of coal and truth be
told I'm sorry I'm just not that big a
fan of her acting why because every
scene she's in looks like a
five-year-old about to throw a temper
tantrum he's conducting illegal
experiments and you were planning on
letting us
this we can't trust her I wanted ice
cream it doesn't take long for them to
come across Ripley was just as eager to
chew the scenery as the aliens are know
if you don't want to play basketball I
know some other indoor sports come on
now give me the ball I guess she's
wearing her ear fuck Hughes today yeah I
bet you didn't know that her alien DNA
gave her super spider-man powers too
the hell are you ah yes and the ability
to shoot a basket without even looking
no doubt another chilling side-effect of
the alien DNA these things must have
taken her sports very seriously
ah so for a while we see people on the
ship mosey around being boring I think
this is supposed to establish character
development but let's face it we're just
getting an early peek at the buff any we
know these guys are alien chow we're
just looking at the clock until they get
munched on then there's bizarre shit
like this you know it's at moments like
this where I realized the only reason we
let Brad Dourif act is because we're
afraid of what he'll do if he doesn't I
have a date with six-year-old boy
come on you were putting the moves on
him
meanwhile Cole tries to break into the
security system that is so high-tech and
so airtight that she has a key chain of
choices to foil it with thank God they
didn't stage in one of the bajillion
guards they have onboard this flying
crock-pot well you're gonna kill me or
what there's no point is there it's true
they'll keep making sequels without her
you got to help me stop this thing
before it gets loose it's too late you
can't stop it
there's lesbian T's for the trailer
better down it to rub my tea party
I don't care I can make it stop
did I mention this director was French
very very French go on get out of here
they're looking for you and the ability
to psychically tell when people are
looking for other people
yet another chilling if not confusing
side-effect of the alien DNA right next
to re-enacting scenes from wild things
I think you're gonna fight that this was
very ill-advised but Cole gets clawed
and they suspect she's some sort of
terrorist trying to stop their plans so
they capture the rest of the pirates to
question them look I don't care whether
you knew or not
you brought a terrorist on board a
military vessel and as far as I am
concerned you will die with her and I
get to say my lives more flamboyant
where's the other one with the chair
don't ever touch me ever uh wouldn't it
make more sense if he just kept the gun
no well maybe they're trying to find the
peaceful route Christy okay Nellie was
pointless for him not to have kept the
gun stop your weapons
you drop that biggest shit release dr.
Mann push on you oh Jesus why stop there
there's so many other obvious objects
you could have bounced it off of well
that's going on the aliens in this cell
trying to figure out a clever way out
buddy there's two kinds of aliens on
this ship those who like the nostalgia
critics transformer cartoon review and
those who don't like the nostalgia
critics transformer cartoon review which
are you I just would have liked to have
seen a more in character where John's
cameo was pointless mathema scriber got
old it just wasn't from do you so the
acid blood from the body breaks through
the walls and allows the aliens to
escape again no guards around to protect
the most dangerous fucking thing in the
galaxy at the moment he'll they don't
even call security after this happens
they just look over the mez making way
for this obvious kill Hey
oh poor this leads to the general and
his army of shoulder hair to do the most
badass thing this division can think Oh
run the fuck away
rhomboid pussies from the thing we were
supposed to be guarding this whole time
the aliens try to break in the Ripley
cell but she has a plan to break open
the metal wall with her bare hands cut
her skin use her acid blood to short out
the wires thus opening the door
Oh her she could have just used the
exact same strength to open the door get
that acid blood doesn't flow much to the
brain oh boy it's like cup of noodles
this looks like a job for a pointless CG
shot
in honor of those who proudly run away
like little girls
proof that dan Hadiya can act with just
a small portion of his brain so of
course after the fucking army runs away
from these things our space pirates try
to hightail it as well or they stop and
walk slowly in the other direction
rather than make it to their only escape
route level 5 sweet delicious idiots on
level 5 so this guy whose name you came
from member gets axed off and they come
across suspect number one it's okay I'll
give you guys a few minutes to run come
on man type ago time to go
dick rat alarm in it yeah I should
probably chase after them I'm so
distracted I just can't focus you know I
think my mind was just distracted by
that ad I saw earlier today how'd it go
again
yeah that was it okay I think they've
had time to simmer in their own sweat
let me just use these psychic alien
powers I just figured out we had to not
figure out that one of my own kind is
about to shoot
fuck I better still get a snow cone was
it everything you hoped for what is your
obsession with turning this into a lesbo
quick so who do I have to fuck to get
off this boat we all know who you like a
fuck seriously where did this come from
let's get out of here no wait a second
here she was the host for these monsters
she's not human why wanted a horse not a
pony she comes
so they come across the wheelchair guy
yeah I know he has a name but let's face
it you're just gonna hold the wheelchair
guy and they also stumble across the
other cloning experiments before Ripley
was made
now this scene is creative and allows
for some cool visuals but when you
really get down to it it's totally
pointless would you really miss anything
if this part of the story was cut out
aside from deform Ripley boobie a
painless poison will do and I'm sure
this will in no way attract other aliens
aboard the ship at all whatever you do
don't draw the aliens attention except
for very loudly destroying as much
equipment as possible very still first
up must be a chick thing they come
across one of the prisoners who has an
alien inside of him and like morons they
decide to bring him along I'm so looking
forward to not getting attached to this
character because obviously he's going
to die yet the same chances as a lawyer
in a theme park filled with Dinosaurs
odds aren't in your favor guy I'm okay
I'm okay they come across a flooded area
where they discovered the aliens have
set a trap for them to birth more babies
oh shit that's bad as you remember in
the first film once those things get on
they never come off the more and more
you pull the tighter and tighter it get
or she just rips it off like waxing a
mustache we can see the other alien
movies where these things really like
just wanting a housefly off of you the
whole time
annoy look like the black guy from
earlier still has calculated aiming that
would make basil of Baker Street blush
occupied by the square look at my sauce
nice triangle
dividing Gautam expensable of opposing
forces
motion and adjusting for the difference
in equilibrium this allows them to start
climbing up just as one of the doctors
from before turns against them way too
trusting
allow me to put this in my bitch later
folder trust me I'll put it to good use
so the alien jumps out of the water and
tries to follow our heroes
wait a minute you're telling me that
this guy can hit with impeccable
accuracy any angle any position knocking
off of every solid object he can find
but a 7-foot alien standing right the
fuck in front of him is constantly
throwing off his aim do you need to wear
a giant bullseye on his head boom god
this is embarrassing he does finally
managed to shoot the damn thing but it
hangs on to his foot which he could
easily kick off but for some reason he
decides to separate himself to save the
rest of the crew
now let us have a moment of silence for
that black guy you know I don't think
that fall would have killed aah he's
dead there's no other aliens down there
together not now he's dead he could
easily just swim out of there any chance
you why can't you just accept the
incredibly rare fact that a black guy
has died in a horror film even though
the fates hunkers were destroyed how
does that even sure but it turns out
Cole made it out okay despite the fact
that she was shot why because she's a
robot of course you're an odd Todd
robots designed by robust right and all
right this leads me to my bitch later
folder first off if she's a robot why
did a bullet hurt her the robots in the
past never took so long to recover from
anything like that second since she fell
in the water why didn't the alien attack
her when it had the chance they're smart
they know she's a threat and third if
she could swim out of the water okay why
a fuc card and the black guy you racist
I don't think you know what that word
means
so after figuring that out lately gets
caught by the aliens but is surprisingly
not hard hey
things get even worse when the doctor
catches up with the crew and holds Cole
hostage we move alright put a cap right
with his little white brain
go ahead she's a fucking robot drop a
weapon yeah sure drop the weapons it's
not like robots can survive anything
extreme except being shot in the chest
being torn in half and getting your head
fucking decapitated but aside from that
robots are very sensitive be careful
here's another goofy scene the prisoner
from earlier feels the aliens starting
to come out so what does he do what
anyone would do if they felt something
starting to pop out of their stomach
gets up goes for a walk beats the living
shit out of a guy and then has the alien
birth through his head keeping the need
for creativity but that makes no sense
I don't remember John Hurt going through
anything like this in the first alien
movie oh my god I feel something about
to breast out of my chest oh that's
strange I have a sudden burst of energy
okay I want to Jessa sighs oh yes do a
little typo Oh it's kicking and just
when you thought things couldn't get any
sillier in this movie we find out that
Brad Dourif is still alive throwing a
really fucking last-minute plot
exposition that Ripley's DNA mixed with
the Queen's DNA now allows her to give
birth to a new life-form
oh and you thought his acting as Chucky
was subtle take a look at this little
piece of Shakespearean gold
I have no idea why I'm cheerfully
invested but the new baby doesn't take
to our mother kindly a beautiful
beautiful little baby
you know this performance is like a
human representation of alien porn
fanfiction I really have no idea what's
going on through his mind and I think
for the sake of all humanity
it should remain that way he should just
come with a sign saying Brad door
no questions dammit no questions so
Ripley gets away it jumps onto the ship
leaving for Earth but of course that's
not bubble sneaks aboard to put it down
I really love how they try to make you
feel for this thing you were introduced
to in the last 10 minutes of the movie
especially when they're given these big
puppy-dog eyes I just want to eat the
manatee and develop wings he's dead a
climb even it is most psychotic they
still try to throw that shit in it's
pretty emotionally clustered I just
wanna play with the puppies cocksucking
motherfucker
mommy why would you do this to me Shelby
trash and hell but they shoot a hole in
the window which forces him to literally
get sucked out
I want a princess Gesell best death ever
weapon
so I'm sure a hole in the window of a
ship re-entering Earth's atmosphere
wouldn't cause any complications at all
so they reenter fine and look over the
new world they have to explore
and after all that lesbian build-up we
finally get our gay kiss for the movie
fuck you so that was alien resurrection
what the hell happened
it's so weird watching a movie franchise
like this go so bizarrely bad especially
with to be fair a lot of good people
working on it the story has a million
whole the characters are just there to
die the idea of mixing Ripley's DNA with
the alien is interesting but doesn't add
too much if anything at all some of the
gross-out deaths are creatively
over-the-top but for the most part it's
just a lame lame flick and a really
disappointing way to end what is now the
poorly named Alien trilogy personally
I'll take my chances with Prometheus
after all when is Ridley Scott ever
directed a bad movie let me dream I'm
the Nostalgia Critic I remember it so
you don't
maybe my heart's on fire if you refuse
me how do you lose me then you'll be
left alone oh baby turbo and tell me I'm
your check please
must be a chick thing